حفله افتتاح مبهر للنسخه الثانيه والعشرين
من بطوله كاس العالم لكره القدم عروض
مذهله سبقها رسائل تدعو للتقارب بين
الشعوب واستذكار لنسخ الموندياليه السابقه
30 دقيقه من سبع فقرات احياها فنانون
عالميون ومزجت بين التقاليد القطريه
والعربيه وثقافات العالميه وفي بدايه
المهرجان الافتتاحيه كيد الشيخ تميم بن
حمد امير قطر ان بلاده بدلاله مجهود كبيره
لتنظيم واحده من انجح البطولات في تاريخ
كاس العالم الشيخ تميم اعرب في كلمته عن
امله في ان يشهد العالم اجمع مهرجان كرويا
مبهرا على ارض الدوحه
[موسيقى]
تتضارب حتى اليوم الارقام حول تكلفه
مونديال قطر اخر الارقام وصلت الى 300
مليار دولار ما هي الارقام النهائيه و
تكلفه الرقم
220 مليار دولار هو الاغلى هي الاغلى
بطوله في العالم منذ عام 1930 يعني ما في
بس هو هذا الرقم لا يشمل فقط
المونديال تحديدا اللي هي تكلفه الملاعب
خلينا نقول اللي هي بنا وسبعه ملاعب جديده
اضافه الى الملعب اللي كان موجود هذه
الملاعب كلفت تقريبا سته ونصف مليار دولار
حتى اليوم ما هو لان هذه كانت التكلفه
بناء هذه الملاعب والباقي كلها راح يبقى
طبعا كبنيه تحتيه للدوله يعني طيب سمر
عندما نتحدث عن المونديال الاغلى في
العالم من حيث التكلفه ما العائدات التي
يمكن ان تحقق ارباحا على قطر يعني كيف
ستستفيد الدول المستضيفه لهكذا انواع من
احداث رياضيه ضخمه هلا هو بدايه اللجنه
همم المنظمه للمونديال تقول انه هناك هو
غير الارباح الماديه هناك ارباح معنويه هي
تضع همم قطر على خارطه العالم مره اخرى
امام كل السياح اللي جايين ف- وبعدين هاي
الفوتبول يعني اكثر يعني اللي توحد العالم
كله خلينا نقول فاكيد يعني هناك فائده
معنويه قبل الماديه بالنسبه للفائده
الماديه هناك توقعت ان تصل الارباح الى
تسعه مليارات دولار طبعا من الانفاق على
سواح من ايضا عندك مثلا همم اماكن
الترفيهيه هي اللي يزوروها ايضا طبعا
طائره وفي الوقت نفسه ما يحتاج ان ينفقه
فعلا السائح هناك اذا اذا فعلا تم وصول
المليون و200,000 سائح يعني لو كل سائح
انفق
5500 دولار سوف يغطي ال 6.5 مليار دولار
اللي تم انفاقها هناك سياح يعني يمكن يمكن
هتنفق اكثر من ذلك بكثير